australien brennt naja auf der karte
wirken die aktuellen brandherde erst mal
relativ übersichtlich doch australien
ist zwanzigmal größer als deutschland
und wenn man die bisher verbrannte
fläche eins zu eins auf deutschland
umlegt wären baden württemberg und
bayern schon komplett zerstört also ganz
süddeutschland verkohlt mindestens die
feiert oben gar nicht mal in den
heißesten gegenden australiens schauen
wir in die gegend der australischen
hauptstadt canberra new south wales und
victoria im südosten eigentlich eher
eine gemäßigte klima zone ähnlich wie
zum beispiel frankfurt am main auf der
südhalbkugel ist jetzt sommer
die höchsttemperaturen in der
betroffenen gegend liegen normalerweise
um die 30 grad
doch schon ende 2009 10 im australischen
frühling herrschten dort extreme wärme
und trockenheit die fehlende
feuchtigkeit im boden wurde zur großen
gefahr so wie übrigens auch im deutschen
rekord sommer 2018 und 2019 die
waldbrandgefahr dadurch riesig bei
rekordhitze frankfurt lag bei 40,2 grad
canberra brach jetzt ebenso seinen
hitzerekord mit 44 grad und durch die
rauchwolken ist sie derzeit eine der
städte mit der größten luftverschmutzung
die krasse hitze kommt mit starken
winden aus den riesigen wüsten zonen des
kontinents ziemlich ungebremst bist an
die südostküste australiens voran bei
uns starten die hitzewellen zwar auch in
der wüste der sahara doch neben den
alpen schlecht vor allem das mittelmeer
meistens die temperatur deutlich ab
solche starken puffer fehlen in den
weiten australiens er an die eine
milliarde säugetiere vögel und reptilien
sollen schon den feuern zum opfer
gefallen sein
gerade die koalas können sich in den
brennenden eukalyptuswälder nicht
schnell genug retten
auch die kleineren waldtiere bei uns
hätten wohl wenig chancen einem solchen
flammen inferno zu entkommen
australien liegt am anderen ende der
welt und zeigt uns für europa trotzdem
was wetter extreme in zeiten des
klimawandels anrichten können